les soirées étudiantes les filles ça va
être la folie allez ciao
est prise à Columbia à la fois du
physique
et fier de toi ok vous êtes qui
le gouverneur veut que tous les immigrés
qui sont détenus soient partis avant que
les élections aient lieu expulsé
tolérance zéro les procureurs est prêt à
abandonner toutes les accusations si
vous vous portez volontaire pour vous
occuper de personnes âgées bienvenue au
foyer du hibou c'est formidable de votre
part de venir apporter votre aide à nos
aînés
non mais vous avez vu ce qu'on nous sert
à bouffer
ce serait plus efficace si c'est toi qui
allait te plaindre rapport à ta couleur
sauf que je suis Argentine
si vous respectez le règlement à la
lettre le temps passera plus vite que
vous ne l'imaginez
comment
je vais me tirer des sérieux tu veux
t'enfuir c'est un accident
[Musique]
super
tout va bien
je peux vous assurer que si vous jouez
le jeu vous serez transformé en partant
d'ici peut-être même que vous
redécouvrirez la valeur de la vie
Monsieur Philippe ça va
il respire plus
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je suis ici parce que je suis
latino ou noir
ou bien les deux